and the public information officer with
the north Las Vegas Police Department
today we are going over an incident that
occurred on the 5000 block of North
Scott Robinson
right now is a brief recap of the
information of what has been put out
already
on December 11 2022 at about 9 16 PM
officers responded to the area of the
5000 block of North Scott Robinson to a
report of a single vehicle traffic
collision
arriving officers located a vehicle that
had struck a tree medical personnel were
called to the scene a juvenile believed
to be around toddler age was pronounced
deceased on scene three others two
adults and one juvenile were transported
to UMC Hospital
the driver of the van is a female
believed to be in her 20s the second
adult passenger is a female but her age
remains unknown at this time
the second juvenile is believed to be
toddler age as well and was later
pronounced deceased at UMC Hospital
two adults remain in serious condition
nlvpd Traffic Division and CSI were
called to the scene
the preliminary investigation revealed
the following
a silver Honda was traveling Northbound
on Scott Robinson from Lone Mountain
the Honda failed to maintain Lane and
sideswiped trees a light pole a wall and
then struck a large palm tree head-on
two juveniles were not wearing
age-appropriate child safety restraints
resulting in the toddler the initial
toddler being decapitated
and the other later succumbing to his
injuries her injuries
speed and impairment are believed to be
factors at this time
the identification of the victims as
well as cause and manner of death will
be released by The Clark County
coroner's office
anyone with any information about this
incident is asked to call nlvpd at
702-633
-911
or call Crime Stoppers
at this time there is no further
information available on the update of
this incident both adults still remain
in the hospital
North Las Vegas PD would like to take
this time to remind all residents that
the dangers of impaired driving and the
need to follow posted speed limit signs
and the use of proper safety restraints
this is a call to action
about DUI speed and proper child
restraints
nlvpd urges parents caregivers and
anyone traveling with children to
protect them by making sure that each
child is secure in the correct car seat
for their age height and weight
as you can see we have car seats on
display
we want to remind the public of the
dangers of driving while impaired
driving after drinking is deadly
yet it still continues to happen across
the United States if you drive while
impaired you could get arrested or Worse
be involved in a traffic collision that
causes Serious injury or death to either
yourself or others
today is a somber day as we already are
honoring the member of
Cameron Ulrich the grandson of two North
Las Vegas locals who passed away on this
day due to being hit by a car in 2018.
now we have this weekend tragedy to look
at the lives of two young children and
seriously injured that seriously injured
two women
these tragedies remind us that we need
to practice Road Safety today and every
day to keep our streets and children
safe
with the holidays coming up everyone
needs to stay vigilant and practice
responsible behaviors
please be safe ride home before plan
your ride before you start the party
choose to a non-drinker who may be a
friend that is a designated driver
if someone you know has been drinking do
not let them get behind the wheel
if you drink do not get behind the wheel
call Rideshare call a taxi there are so
many options these things are very
avoidable
and always wear your seat belt it is the
best defense against impaired drivers
the city of North Las Vegas takes all
traffic accidents seriously the health
and safety of all residents is a top
priority
though the efforts of our grant
Administration office the city was
recently awarded with additional funds
by the Nevada Department of Public
Safety
these monies will help fund initiatives
including and addressing
DUIs and reckless driving which
collaborates with other law enforcement
agencies
it does also help with increased
presence of officers at busy pedestrian
intersections crosswalks in areas of
need to decrease fatalities
funds to support dedicated staff in time
and programming to address speeding
violations enhanced informants of safety
and child safety seat laws and to reduce
distracted driving and impaired driving
we currently have displays of child
safety seats that people need to be
aware of
a regular car seat is not to be used for
a child
this is very avoidable
at this time
any questions that you may have can be
addressed to the email address of pdpio
at cityofnorthlasvegas.com
after this we will be taking a car seat
demo downstairs for everyone to see the
proper installment of a car seat
thank you very much